♪ ♪
>> Sean: IVANKA AND FIRED
THEIR CONTRIBUTOR FOR HIS
OUTRAGEOUS COMMENTS ABOUT
ISRAEL.
THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF INSANITY
AT THE SO-CALLED FACTS FIRST
NETWORK.
HERE ARE SOME MORE OF THEIR
HYSTERICAL, CRAZY, BIASED
COVERAGE.
>> AS ITS PRESIDENT TRYING TO
IMPERSONATE HUGO CHAVEZ?
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> HE KNOWS HOW TO HANDLE AN
ASSET THAT IS WHAT HE IS DOING
WITH THE PRESIDENTS.
>> WHAT WE SEE A GOVERNMENT COME
OUT AND SAY, WE CANNOT SIDE WITH
THE GOVERNMENT?
>> BUYS TRUMP SHOWING SYMPATHY
FOR WHITE NATIONALIST
>> ONE GENERATION, WHAT DOES
THAT TELL YOU?
>> WE CAN SAY HIS WORDS HAVE
ABSOLUTELY EMBOLDENED WHITE
SUPREMACISTS.
>> 16 TWEETS TO START THE NEW
YEAR.
HE HAS NOT FOLLOWED.
A LEADER WHO IS NOT FIT FOR
OFFICE.
>> PRESIDENT SNOWFLAKE.
EVERYTHING HE SAYS, THEY ARE
MEAN TO ME.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> THIS WAS A WHITE LASH.
IT WAS A WHITE LASH AGAINST A
CHANGING COUNTRY.
A WHITE LASH AGAINST A BLACK
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: WE NOW BRING IN MEDIA
REPORTER FROM THE HILL.
I GUESS MY FAVORITE AND ALL THAT
IS, DR. HUMPTY DUMPTY GIVEN HIS
DIAGNOSIS.
>> I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD EVER
BE GIVING SOMEBODY WHO IS
MARRIED TO A DOCTOR.
WE DO WANT TO PLAY A DOCTOR ON
TV WHEN YOU ARE BASICALLY DOING
A DIAGNOSIS FROM A FAR.
THAT IS NEVER A GOOD LOOK.
OBVIOUSLY HE HAD TO BE FIRED IN
THE SITUATION.
YOU MENTIONED IT BEFORE.
FREE PALESTINE FROM THE RIVER TO
THE SEA.
THAT IS RIGHT OUT OF A SCRIPT
THAT CALLS FOR THE ANNIHILATION
OF ISRAEL.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT BIG ON FIRINGS AND THE
SORT OF SITUATIONS BUT THIS WAS
UNAVOIDABLE.
HERE'S THE THING.
THE SCENE AND HAS 40 TO 50
CONTRIBUTORS
UNDERNEATH THEIR UMBRELLA.
FIRING HIM ISN'T THAT HARD OF A
THING TO DO BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
DOZEN OTHER PEOPLE YOU CAN JUST
PLUG IN.
THE OTHER BIGGER NAMES THAT YOU
SHOW DURING THAT MONTAGE, PEOPLE
THAT ARE ON THE AIR OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE ANCHORS OF MY NETWORK.
THERE ARE A LOT HARDER TO FIRE.
UNLIKE CALLING FOR THEM TO BE
FIRED.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO FIRE EVERY
SNOW PERSON THAT CALLED THE
PRESIDENT EIGHT RACIST OR
FASCIST OR QUESTIONED HIS MENTAL
HEALTH, 90% OF THIS INDUSTRY.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I AM ARGUING, IT IS ALMOST EVERY
SECOND OF EVERY MINUTE OF EVERY
HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
STORMY DANIELS, RUSSIA.
MICHAEL AVENATTI TV.
THEY SAY THEY ARE REPORTERS.
I MIGHT HOST AND I DO SOME
OBJECTIVE REPORTING.
A LOT OF OPINION.
THEY SAY THEIR NEWS.
THEY ARE DISHONEST.
>> THAT IS THE THING.
IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
DON LEMON, HE IS CALLED AN
ANCHOR ON THE NETWORK.
HE IS SOMEONE WHO GIVES
OPINIONS.
IT GETS CONFUSING AFTER A WILD
BIRD SAME WITH ANDERSON COOPER.
THEY ARE ANCHORS THEREFORE THEY
SHOULD BE IN THERE ASKING
QUESTIONS AND GATHER
INFORMATION.
JIM ACOSTA ASKING QUESTIONS AND
GATHERING INFORMATION'S.
ALL THESE PEOPLE SHARE THEIR
ENTER MOST FEELINGS ON CERTAIN
TOPICS.
THEIR EMOTIONS.
THEY DEBATE IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS AND THAT IS NOT THE
JOB IS AND THAT IS WHERE
MISTRUST COMES TO WITHIN PEOPLE
WATCHING AT HOME AND WATCHING
THE MEDIA.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHO THE ANCHORS
ARE FROM THE OPINION PEOPLE TO T
ARE FROM THE OPINION PEOPLE TO O
THE ABUNDANCE ANYMORE.
WHEN THEY HEAR A SIDE BEING
GIVEN, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
CONCLUDE FROM THAT BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO
DRAW THE VIEWER TO A CONCLUSION
INSTEAD OF LETTING THEM DRAW
THEIR OWN CONCLUSION.
THAT IS A BIG PROBLEM IN OUR
INDUSTRY.
>> Sean: WE SOMETIMES DO